all right I now am glad I genuinely am
glad
to be able to do what so many of you
delightful Mega people have been telling
me I should do talk about the Biden
crimes talk about the Biden crimes let's
talk about them Donald Trump was
indicted on 34 37 felony counts last
week and on that day you had Fox with a
front page headline about the Biden
bribery and you had Trump speaking at
Bedminster talking about Biden's
documents and all of these different
things so let's talk a little bit about
it we're going to talk about later about
some of the allegations made by
Republicans that Joe Biden has committed
crimes that doesn't really sound like
due process to me but we'll get that to
that in a moment but let's talk about
the new bombshell about Biden bribery if
you actually question Republicans
specifically about what they are
alleging here
you get them mostly to admit
they don't know whether the Biden
bribery tapes actually exist they
haven't spoken to one of the main people
making these allegations in three years
even those who are sure the tapes exist
say they actually don't know if they are
reputable or trustworthy so let's talk
about Biden bribery and you are very
quickly going to realize as of right now
there isn't anything that we would call
evidence on the day of Trump's
indictment
so many of you wrote to me and said why
won't I talk about this well it's not
that I won't talk about it it's that we
actually need to know is there anything
worthy of talking about here is
Republican Congressman James Comer not
sandbagged by some left-wing interviewer
but interviewed on Newsmax and he says
the tapes the tapes everybody is
building this case around he's not even
sure if those tapes are legitimate when
will you be able to confirm if these
recordings are legit how long is that
going to take
well I can confirm that the recordings
were in the 1023 remember I was okay
let's pause it right there
the 10 23. the 1023 they are referring
to is a form that asserts the existence
of such tapes it is not evidence of the
tapes what he says is the form mentions
the tapes
that's like if I make a statement and I
I could write down on this piece of
paper down here that Hunter Biden's
laptop is actually you know a Nintendo
Wii the fact that I've written it down
doesn't mean that it is true okay but
let's continue Senator Grassley when we
saw the unredacted version okay so Chris
Grassley was saying alleged yesterday so
these recordings are legit you can
confirm they are legitimate they were I
can confirm they were listed in the 1023
you understand that right he he he can't
confirm that these recordings are
legitimate he can just say they are
referred to on a piece of paper the FBI
redacted we don't know if they're legit
or not but we know that the foreign
National claims he has them exactly we
don't know if they are legitimate this
is the Blockbuster that so many of our
Maga viewers are saying I'm ignoring
okay here is James Comer saying they
haven't heard from the so-called major
witness in three years with respect to
the tapes look it mentioned in the FBI
form that the oligarch had 17 tapes of
Biden two with Joe Biden except in the
bride that he used that as an insurance
this Oliver as a high-ranking was a
high-ranking member uh or owner of
barisma
yes that is exactly right so have you
had anything could you show them
unfortunately nobody's had any contact
with him for the last three years
[Laughter]
okay so the Blockbuster that I ignored
on the day Trump was indicted in an
extraordinarily detailed and tight
indictment per Chris Christie that day I
am guilty of ignoring the Blockbuster
story in which a supposed Russian
oligarch
who hasn't been heard from for three
years
asserted according to a 1023 form that
he has tapes which we don't know exist
and even if they exist we don't know if
they are legitimate tapes here's
Marjorie Taylor green also admitting it
the audio is poor she's speaking to
CNN's Manu Raju here but listen closely
to what she says
okay so she first says these audio
recordings that were made are a really
big deal
now does the guy have the audio
recordings I don't know and I don't
think we're going to find out wow that
is really quite a story Marjorie really
really unbelievable uh and then when you
actually go through a lot of the
reporting on this you see that there is
a lot of uh shakiness shakiness The
Daily Beast reporting Republicans admit
they don't know if the Biden bribery
tapes really exist Newsmax had an
article earlier this week of Congressman
Waltz saying that a blind eye is being
turned to the Biden documents we're not
even really sure that the Biden
documents refer to things that exist you
have an article from the New York Post
barisma boss in alleged Biden bribe
scheme claims to have 15 taped
conversations with Hunter and two with
Joe according to Chuck Grassley is Chuck
Grassley telling the truth is the guy
actually a barisma boss did he actually
claim to have those tapes do the tapes
exist are the tapes legitimate do the
tapes even expose the alleged
criminality they claim is there and then
also Fox news reporting barisma audio
tapes could be
could be a cataclysmic event for
President Biden according to Trump's
completely weaponized delusional former
acting AG Matt Whittaker there is very
little here my friends the hunter Biden
laptop okay the laptop maybe is real
there were three MacBooks dropped off by
someone to a Blind repair man who
couldn't actually see whose they were
but he saw a sticker on one of the
MacBooks for Beau Biden's charity and
said this is Hunter Biden's laptop it
didn't really contain much other than
some extraordinarily vague
unsubstantiated reference and explicit
pictures of Hunter Biden himself
not exactly a major Blockbuster story
The Biden bribery tapes do they actually
exist we don't really know right now the
Biden quote classified document Scandal
let's suspend that one for now because
I'll dig into it a little bit later and
then Hillary's crimes of course she was
cleared of criminal wrongdoing and we'll
talk about that later the one thing out
of all of this that I can tell you is
real is that there is a real 37 count
federal felony indictment against Donald
Trump it contains photographic evidence
it refers to audio recordings it is
extraordinarily tight according to Chris
Christie that is real that we know
exists but these Maga people keep
writing to me and saying David you're
not willing to talk about XYZ I'm glad
to talk about it when I have time like
today there's just really not that much
to say about it and that's the reason
I'm not giving it more coverage